cody's with us in Branson hi Cody how
are you pretty are you doing better than
I deserve what's up
well me and my wife run the process of
beginning to pay off debt and we've been
married about seven years bought a home
right out of the gate and and then she
owed some debt over the course of the
last seven years we have been offered a
home basically free of charge my in-laws
own it or not using it that you guys
want move into it go for it whether as
long as you want and so what we're doing
is we are renting out our current home
and moving into this other home to kind
of reappropriation funds towards that my
main question is currently my wife has
about $40,000 in student loans then we
have an additional probably thirty five
to forty thousand dollars and just as a
random loan and car payments credit
cards things like that and what is your
household income our household income is
about a hundred thousand a year cool all
right and my main question though is I
know normally with like the baby set
program you start with the biggest nor
qa2 the smallest known opposite office
okay I'm sorry
and with that her student loans are
adjustable rate will that change the way
you would do anything no all right you
still start with the smallest and go up
because they're not going to have time
to address you're going to be debt-free
in two years okay cuz you're going to
live on nothing being her eyes rice and
beans if you're willing to move out of
your house and rent your own house out
you're willing to do almost anything and
you need to go on beans and rice rice
and beans don't see it inside of a
restaurant let you're working there no
vacations we're on a tight tight tight
tight tight scorched-earth budget we're
gonna get this mess cleaned up fast rip
the band-aid off fast and that's 40,000
a year for two years out of a hundred
that leaves you sixty live on - taxes
you can do that but it's tight well
honestly we just came from less than
that
for two of us and we were still making
all the bills we're making now okay good
then you can do it faster than that so
we when we see 80 grand and 80 grand in
debt 40 a year for two years you're done
right yep and so it's not gonna have
time to adjust enough to matter
okay so list your debts smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one because
you're going to be living so tight and
you're going to be sacrificing so deeply
that you're going to need to
psychologically and emotionally see the
progress and that's why paying off the
little one works best because you just
you bust it through and you start to
believe you start to believe and you
just start going yeah we got this yeah
we can do this and because that little
ones gone that one's gone and keep a big
old chart on the refrigerator draw big
red lines to it as you knock it out so
you can walk through the kitchen and
point at the enemy and go you're the
enemy Sallie Mae I hate you you ugly
woman
you know Bank of America get out of my
life
you just start talking to these people
because they've been screwing you over
they've been taking your life and you
let them do it but you now have declared
war on the enemy and you work too hard
to spend your whole life being broke
people you guys it's time America you
work too hard to put up with this crap
off these banks you be treated the way
you're treated by these people think
about the way they talk to you when they
call you why in the world do we let them
into our lives like this you deserve
better change it you're on fire Cody you
got this man this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]